I'm really happy because we've I think
you did my various late night shows you
were on like 11 or 12 times yeah and
always a reliably great guest and uh and
and I thought
in that format I couldn't really get to
know you because it's it's it's a very
different situation there's a band and
it's you've got seven minutes with Zach
and then we move on you know we go and
uh I thought I I'd really like to get to
know this guy and I started to do
looking into your past and I was really
surprised by a couple of things which is
I didn't realize you grew up in this uh
it's sort of a religiously schizophrenic
situation where your dad is Jewish and
your mom is Protestant no she converted
well before they got married because he
was super into Judaism at the time and
um and he wasn't going to marry a
non-jewish woman so she converted
she was Protestant when she met him yes
yeah and he said I love you um but you
would definitely need to convert for
this to go further and she she didn't
really have much connection to her
religion and she was interested and she
was very in love and she said okay I'll
do it I love you and and I don't I'm not
really connected to my own religion so
I'll I'll do it and then she as what as
what happens with some people she got
super into it and like made my dad more
more religious like she made the family
kosher and uh this is not uncommon this
hat this is quite I mean I've heard of
this and I've known people that have
gone through this where someone converts
and then be almost because it's new to
them they they go farther yeah because
also I think some some of those people
are looking for a a thing a looking for
a passionate uh group or or or or or
religion and then when someone provides
it with them in a really educated way
they go all in they're like this is
amazing I haven't had this so it was
kind of funny that then we were then we
were like really religious and Coach
well sir I wasn't born yet but by the
time I was around we were kosher and um
you know as far even as extreme is like
doing separate dishes for meat and dairy
and like like for real kosher and um and
it's it surprised me as someone who was
raised Catholic when I've had
uh I mean years ago I remember talking
to a friend who's another comedy writer
who was very Orthodox and he had just
moved into a new apartment and there
were things that are that took me by
surprise he's I remember talking to this
friend of mine once and he said yeah I
can't talk right now there's a rabbi
here with a blowtorch what and I said
what and he said well he's in the
kitchen and there's a special Rabbi that
comes who uh uses a blowtorch to burn
out any trace of I'm guessing pork or
shellfish or anything that could
possibly they call it trafe which is uh
I don't know if it's Yiddish or Hebrew
for things that are not Kosher I was
told we never did this but that if we
messed up we the plate would have to be
buried in the backyard like if if you if
you put meat and cheese on that on that
plate it was it was done so that way
we're gonna have to we know no one's
ever followed through on this and I
don't know if I I'm I'm I'm naive if to
know if if people who are super
religious Orthodox really do that but
that was sort of in the back of my
childhood brain was like don't mess up
or this poor Plate's gonna get buried
wait a little bit she's got on that
plate and then suddenly it gets fired in
the air and a bunch of rabbis with
shotguns shoot it to Pieces rabbi's been
shot because doing uh I just love him
they were just like and that's they were
specialized that's what they did they
had guns they were ready to go and they
would shoot these these trays I love
traits I've heard that before I've never
heard that one I wish that was my rap
name
I am rapping and I'm DJ trades I don't
know if you I think I could more likely
go to a an Israeli rapper than you
I rap about all the things that are
traif and that we can't eat what was
funny is that my what was funny that so
my mom then they got divorced when I was
around eight and my my new stepfather
was not into this at all so and then my
mom again being in in love and and
accepting a new life was like yeah
forget about all that what
what a whip
because I was enjoying custody so we
would go my sister and I uh I have two
older brothers who who opted out but my
sister and I would go uh a week with one
and then a week with the other and we
were with my mom we were not Kosher and
not religious and we were with my dad he
was strict kosher and religious it was
it was a trip that's unbelievable yeah
it was pretty crazy and so and then when
I was when I turned 13 I had a bar
mitzvah and I I did this sort of Jiu
Jitsu move on because he was all about
how now you are a man
and I said well if I'm a man now
I would like to eat a cheeseburger wow
how'd that go over he to his credit he
he he he he knew he's by the way I don't
mean to say that he was an incredibly
loving man he was just a religious man
um he and so he he he got it I mean he
smiled at the Jiu Jitsu move right but
then he knew I was battling this thing
of like Mom's house one week his house
and so it became like when you're in my
home I want I asked that you respect
being kosher but but out in the world
and whatever you are a young man now and
you can do whatever you want
it's so interesting because I would uh
so many people that if your name comes
up I think the first thing they would
think is because they they know you as
you know primarily as this performer uh
on screen and you're a very likable and
chippers seeming and I happen to know
that a lot of anxiety when you were
young yeah was that do you think it was
that stem from the divorce or do you
think that was just a natural condition
I think I definitely was a very anxious
child I got diagnosed with OCD as a very
young I was doing a lot of the tapping
stuff that that people suffer from yeah
and um it would it would manifest in a
weird way like the example I give to
people who had never had experienced any
of this at all is you're a child and you
say if you don't kiss that teddy bear
six times before you leave the room
something bad could happen to the family
and then you're even as a young in your
young brain you go I know that's not
real probably but just to be safe let me
do it exactly do I want to risk it why
risk it right it's like superstitions
from for for regular people like you
don't you don't walk under a ladder you
don't do this you don't do that but it's
for in a child's brain it's like why
would I possibly why would I possibly
risk it but then then the kisses of the
teddy bear you didn't quite get right it
looks felt like did I do six total I
think I miscounted the bear doesn't look
satisfied
the bear is seeing someone else
the bear yeah the bear love has gone out
of this once the sex goes it's over says
the bear that's hilarious I never
thought of it like that like the bear
was like give me more yeah but um but
anyway
um so there was a lot of that tapping
stuff and and and yeah I think of course
the divorce was stressful and and joint
custody is stressful and you know you
would get settled in one home and then
then Sunday you'd have to switch to a
completely different environment right
and my sister and I would be quite upset
um because both my environments were so
different and then it would take to like
Wednesday to kind of get acclimated
right and then and then you moved Sunday
so there was a lot of
um stress uh I don't I don't mean to
blame that on my my parents entirely
um I think some of it is is genetic and
I was an anxious boy yeah I I relate to
that just because I think I had uh and
and you know my parents stayed together
uh I tried to get them to separate uh
I'm still working on it my dad just
turned 94. my mom's 91 and I still I
think it's time now that they I said
look just try living separately for a
while I think they should see other
people uh but are you close what's that
close to getting dude I think I'm pretty
close several times I've driven my
father to a motel uh but he won't get
out of the car but
um you drove me well I say look it's
nice that's a that's a Comfort Hotel
singular newly single at 94 sounds
pretty bad yeah any hotel that still
says free HBO yeah on the sign you know
they haven't changed that sign since
1983.